it looks like untouched nature but
actually a lot of hard work has gone
into these mud flats on the part of
Essex County nature conservationists
like Chris tile if he had his way the
entire Essex coastline would be
reclaimed for nature the wetlands
provide nesting grounds for many bird
species they also help prevent flooding
along the coast the mud flat is is an
amazingly productive habitats got the
correct value of a mars bar in one
square meter so far it's actually more
productive than the farmland behind us
earlier generations on wallasey Island
reclaimed this farmland from the ocean
now bird conservationists want to undo
that and turn it back into mud flats and
salt marshes this is going to be new
coastal grazie marsh we've lost about
thirty two percent of our coastal grazie
marsh since nineteen thirty-two so it's
important to put that back but then
there'll be a seawall and beyond that
will be our new intertidal habitat so
over six hundred hectares of new salt
marsh mud flat and ceylon lagoons the
farmland will need to be flooded with
seawater but first it needs to be
covered with a layer of soil to
withstand the tides the land has to be
at exactly the right level right now
though the next delivery has been
delayed the hauling machine is out of
service eventually several million tons
of soil will be needed to cover 670
hectares of farmland when it's done it
will be a paradise for birds and for
nature lovers but where will they get so
much soil
the answer is here right in central
London as part of the cross rail project
new railway tunnels are being dug in
various locations and ten new commuter
rail and metro stations are under
construction the soil is first cleaned
and then transported by rail and ship to
Essex Colin Nichols is a tunnel engineer
and project manager for a section of the
new railway line he's in charge of the
Whitechapel station in East London okay
we got some London play it's been
excavated out as you can see behind me
there's a stockpile that we just
temporarily put in the tunnel and this
is then moved out with them with dumpers
to the muck scoop in the pit bottom
taking up to the surface and then taken
off towards the island the Whitechapel
station is located 30 metres underneath
the surface down here the soil is very
clean but right now work has stalled the
air vents need to be repaired it's just
one of many surprises they've
encountered when they started digging
the workers found more than they'd
bargained for they found medieval skulls
and coins and Roman artifacts they could
have an awful lot of bodies that they've
dug up over the years that we're around
London wall and so they found bones that
they need to be exhumed I think it's
something that reason 400 bones and what
bodies have been found I hope at that
time most Londoners have no idea what's
happening down below them still the
entire city stands to benefit the new
rail lines will transport 200 million
passengers a year and boost the city's
rail capacity by ten percent the new
railway and underground stations are
also incorporating ecological standards
the Whitechapel station for example will
have solar energy panels and a green
roof the City of London asked Ross rail
to make sure the soil is used for
projects that will benefit the public
here in Essex the London soil is more
than welcome fortunately the machines
are also working again
the nature conservationists and the
construction firms are working closely
together Chris tile is collaborating
with siobhan wall who is cross rails
representative for the wallasey wetlands
project they're making sure the earth is
spread at exactly the right level and
they're monitoring the soil quality
we've got to work with what is the
natural material underneath central
London and that changes depending on the
geology of the term where the tunnel is
and where this news stations are it's
always a challenge and some areas it's a
surprise when we wait until we've dug it
to find out what that material is once
the soil has been spread and the land
flooded it will take a few more years
before plants and animals return to the
new wetlands wallasey Allen was claimed
from the sea 500 years ago it was a
superb mix of five separate salt marsh
islands and what we're trying to do here
with cross raleys bring that habitat
back for the future generations to enjoy
but it will take a few more years before
peace and quiet returns to wallasey
Islands the machines won't be leaving
until 2019 at the earliest but one day
the marsh Birds will be nesting here on
soil brought in from London